you're gonna give me a timeout during
this one because i know you have no
interest in the xfl but but chris a lot
of people do and now that the rock
has purchased the xfl along with his
ex-wife and business manager danny
garcia and red bird capital they got it
for 15 million i was stunned yesterday
how do you buy the xfl for 15 million
here's how you buy it for 15 million
there were no other qualified bidders
for the xfl which tells you what it's
worth right now i mean a sports league
and a pandemic when we have no idea when
you can sell tickets for people to come
watch your games we have no idea whether
or not espn abc and fox will want to
continue to televise those games
especially if you try to play in the
spring and there are sports that have
been moved from the fall of the spring
like maybe college football uh it's not
going to be the most lucrative property
but they have a vision for it they
believe in the product it may take a few
years for it to get back to what it was
starting to be they had some decent tv
ratings they started to drop off they
were facing some stiff competition march
madness was coming before the the real
march madness arrived in the form of the
pandemic but i'm telling you you get
there aren't a lot of people whose names
you can attach to something like the xf
valve i agree and have
instant excitement and there aren't many
that are going to trump vince mcmahon
and the rock is one of the ones that
takes this to another level and it gets
me even more interested and chris you
were completely disinterested you got to
admit when you heard the rock was
getting involved you at least had a
little bit of a flicker it opened my
eyes there's no doubt yeah i mean
because just about everything the guy
touches you know turns to gold i mean he
sees what he's the most uh is the
richest movie star in the world right
now i think per movie or per year or
whatever it is either way he's breaking
it in
very smart we know he's got a football
background you know he is the kind of
name or figurehead that could maybe sway
a young kid or whatever else to to think
about oh xfl maybe one day if they can
get in a spot can challenge the nfl or
steal a player or two or whatever it may
be but that's where it's got to get to
so he's going to have to work on
publicizing the league getting it to be
getting to a place where yeah everybody
takes it serious and wants to do it but
i still think hey the big obstacle is
going to be always come down to what we
said to begin with you know it's we just
when you need some stars and that's
where dwayne johnson the rock is gonna
have to start thinking about
how he's gonna get those guys on his
team you know i know there's there's
plenty of guys out there to build teams
and certainly some solid football
players that aren't in the nfl that
probably deserve to be and you'll get
some good quality football but we like
to watch stars in this country we do
that's that's that's what it's all about
and we want to see guys that can do
special things and that's where to me
will be the biggest hurdle into
legitimizing it and really you know
turning the corner to where somebody
like the guys like me will want to watch
it
yeah and that's the key they need to
attract stars they need to cultivate
stars they need to keep their stars that
was one of the issues that i had and
they were starting to right the
quarterback for the houston roughnecks
whose name i've already forgotten do you
remember who it was well i can't
remember who it was but he was playing
really well he's the guy that was
interested
for a cup of coffee you're talking about
the carolina panthers walker walker pj
walker yeah jay walker yeah he's he's
well i didn't pay attention i couldn't
remember what team he was on so when you
said houston roughnecks it did nothing
for me i just if i was gonna get there
when you said he was the best
quarterback for sure yes
but but they need star players they need
star power and until they have star
players the star power comes from the
rock so look i'm i'm interested in it
there are people out there who want more
football there are people out there who
want more things to bet on and i think
as we see more and more states legalize
sports wagering to rebuild their budgets
post pandemic it's going to be weed and
wagering those are the two ways to
rebuild your state budgets people are
going to want things to bet on and i
think they're going to be like one of
the two uh the xfl oh i know you do uh
we'll try to get you to like the other
one as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports